so Krypton we were just talking about it
is is the culmination of many years of
nerdom that could only exist now I think
all the foundation that sci-fi is built
in their decade plus of this format and
where nerd culture is when you guys came
to this project you're both already in
the Nerds zeitgeist what was it like
reading that script for the very first
time oh it was so exciting I think you
know we were sort of saying with the
success of shows like the flash and
arrow and stuff like that we had an
opportunity to do something it was kind
of different mhm and I think it was
really bold like from the beginning we
knew that we were telling a story of an
Elseworlds yeah this is an alternate
timeline as a super bold ideas nothing
had really been done on TV before so to
be a part of that was was really
exciting yeah and I think because of the
evolution of the nerd demos you say I
think the public are open to prequel
their argue to new legends new stories
and from the point of view of Zod and
the characters we'll discuss later they
haven't actually met them at this level
before so this is a really exciting time
to be exploring the dark side you guys
are both saw two sides of a very similar
coin in that your character is a legacy
character in who he represents as a
house and your character has been a
legacy character like Terence Stamp is
played at Michael Shannon so you're both
known but in such different ways was it
intimidating stepping in shoes that had
never been stepped in in quite the way
or had been stepped in so thoroughly in
such different ways was was it
interesting approaching these characters
because of the legacy they they bring to
the table I think it's a wonderful thing
of course there's the added pressure
there because it's Superman and Superman
is a character who means so much to
millions of people and I've always been
a fan he's meant so much to me
personally so of course you don't let
anyone down but that's also a good thing
it's a wonderful thing Superman is a
great thing so it's all about doing
justice to that and for me it the joy
was trying to find the areas where sag
is different like seg isn't the the
finished package you know he has to grow
to be a hero all of season one for him
was about trying to understand who he
was and what his role was in this world
and at the end of that season he finally
figures it out and sort of the last
minute and
he's on that journey but he doesn't have
to be Superman he sort of just thinks of
himself as a guy like the cool thing
about that character was I got to make
it my own very often when you're
stepping into these roles you're
stepping into the shoes of a legacy
where there have been other actors and
stuff like that but for me I got the to
see the wonderful work of Christopher
Reeve and Henry Cavill and Tom Welling
and actors like that and borrow that but
also one of my main inspirations for it
was Harrison Ford and Indiana Jones you
know so I really got to create a
character that was completely my own as
well as play you know as well as a pay
tribute to what's come before oh it's
beautiful yeah and for myself when I
first went up for the job I went up for
a guy who's called ma'am with dark hair
so thankfully I didn't know I was going
up for Zod because that would have been
intimidation then when she got the ethos
or the the core of the character with
the way they wrote the scenes for me to
learn you realize the duplicitous and
the Machiavellian element of the
character they wanted me to play then we
get to the the actual recording you
realize you are General Zod and then you
go well they've written this backstories
history this is scenario so clearly and
the fact that I know the history we
talked about this the fact I know what's
coming
informs everything I'm doing now so this
is all the surprises love stuff with my
dad and my mom which was a bit of a
surprise but the I have a core role
which is to stop that annihilation and
the debate now between us is how do we
do that you know and I think we have to
put two sides of the same coin with our
love of Krypton
but um yeah lovely to explore this
character what I love about it that the
show in general is is we're talking
before about how it balances the villain
the hero and almost equal measure it's
so important to have the villain work
for the hero to work and I think that
the evolution of where comics are now
like when in daredevil and these shows
where you're very invested in both
having that foundation before you
actually really knew who he was what
were some of the choices you've decided
about him before they gave you like all
the all the backstory and work like who
is he to you and then interpreting that
for the screen well the universe works
in mysterious ways and one of the things
that I did just before and Bank
embarking on this role was I actually
had to do the Paradise Lost for the
British Library so and I played the
Satan characters
when off and really studied it and
really really studied it and came away
and just thought fantastic thank you so
much because I saw the Superman figure
as an angel I saw it differently I saw
myself as a fallen angel I saw I took
that as my sort of my legend and then
your into an interesting thing because
you talking about pride and hubris and I
was born the day after God so I'm angry
about that why the hell do you think you
know why you the man and I'm not the man
so you have that that's going on in your
character making which will distort your
decisions so you know that you know if
you allow those things to get to that
emotion you forget things and this is
where having said yeah like the family
used I'm starting to work out what
potentially went wrong with me really
wanting to know you know he was happy in
his ignorance but unfortunately that I'm
not allowed to
well in that anymore so he's a it
becomes complex I love the idea of Zod
as a fallen angel and beautifully
mirrors all the the the biblical
parallels of Superman but at an earlier
stage and I think that that's one of the
strengths of the show is it lets you
play with mythology without you breaking
mythology you're saying else world we're
getting characters in the show I never
thought we'd see in the big screen
much less a serialized screen yeah every
week I get to like Lobos here Breanna
next year what is going on when you
first saw these characters fully formed
what was there what was the craziest
moment of like guys do you dear you
weren't Doomsday's here today like what
was it yes like no it's like do they
practical yeah we haven't we have a CGI
dooms there when he's in action CGI but
there's a puppy and it's it's amazing it
needs it a most it's huge doomsday is
real and that's the most incredible
thing I remember seeing that publicly
for the first time and it's you know
it's a it's an animatronic but it's
terrifying
it really is terrifying yeah and thrust
like it's something that we're so proud
to did this show was devised as a way
into the DC cosmic universe to introduce
more characters like Brainiac and Lobo
and Adam Strange and characters like
that so for us to be able to debut these
characters and you know particularly
Brainiac you know we took from the Jeff
Jones and Garrett Frank run and that was
that was the main inspiration for our
Brainiac and to come up with our
interpreter
these characters and and and do them
justice on the screen that it means
everything to us you see black written
just oh yeah loving and then you see the
FX and a makeup department gosh
yeah a commitment from the whole crew I
mean we're the acting Department and we
take that very seriously we behave and
we train and we work that we get to set
quick we just our discipline group
because we're working with some of the
best in the business so we all have to
put our heart and soul in oh yeah and
then you see doomsday hmm and you see
there's a scene where I I was seen with
him with that only too much detail I
asked him a question which is quite a
moving question and you see his chest
move and it really moved me actually I
was like that's the level we're at and
that's stuff I'm interested in is bigger
that what's the thing that moves you
about why because there is no it's like
Frankenstein's Mary Shelley it's so many
literal things you know it's there is no
monster it was just a creature it was
the way which it was treated that made
him a monster that's the whole point of
science fiction for me and as as the
mother of it I think they are alluding
to that the wonderful thing about all of
it and all of these characters is that
we don't really think of it as heroes
and villains they're all incredibly
motivated to do the things that they do
and one of things I loved about Zordon
season one was how much said respected
him and how much seg was was constantly
on the backfoot and he was constantly in
crisis as a character he really had no
agency or choice over being a hero he
kind of just had the beader
and all of a sudden he meets this man
who is strong and brave and has a plan
and knows exactly what he's doing and
tells him the truth Adam Strange lied
Adam Strange didn't tell him that
Krypton was going to be destroyed and
all of a sudden there's someone who said
yes your grandson was my enemy I never
took pleasure in that all I've ever
wanted to do was save this planet and
it's true he's not lying
and and so seg goes into season two
knowing that there is a good man in
there and that may be their ideal there
are there are parts of it that can meet
up there can be a middle ground and all
of those scenes that we have together
are so wonderfully loaded not only
because seg like Superman is constantly
trying to save everyone even in
but also because it's his son you know
and he believes truly that there is good
in him one of the things that's so hard
about Superman for me as the character
is is humanizing him and I think that's
one of the the strengths of the
character he's written well is you're
seeing the humanity and something so
removed from humanity I never thought
we'd see the humanity of Superman by way
of Sehgal and Zod yeah I think that's
the strength of the show of amongst many
but when as comic book fans you heard
about the the concept of this show yeah
how did that alter your perspective of
Superman now that you're part of the
thing that makes him human to us yeah I
mean it's you know this is this is
something that's absolutely massive you
know it's Superman is one of the
greatest icons in all the fiction and as
I said before someone who means a great
deal to so many people and and there are
so many fantastic storytellers an
artists who've worked within this legacy
so for us to be here now and doing our
best to leave it better than we found it
it's a real honor I look forward to
darkening him in the future coming we
can do things so if this insufferable
being does appear you know but it's just
really interesting we can really nice no
sufferable talk but there's there's
elements of that humanity you talk about
the way I like okay yeah okay so what's
the best thing I can do well I would
just let me know that I don't mean you
because I respect the humanity and the
goodness and the justness of your
character yeah that line now I did and
it sort of changes the DNA a bit right
literally changed my DNA so therefore
I'm part of his family now so it's like
okay maybe I'll just toughen him up a
bit yeah yeah glasses off there is that
wonderful
tell your father it's if there is there
is that wonderful thing if they're
constantly trying to get the other to
see their side mm-hmm that if there's
one person that Zod could convert it
would be saggy if he could choose mm-hmm
and if there's one person that seg could
save he would want it to be Zod you know
that Dan has such a wonderful loaded
relationship absolutely
so with you both being comic book fans
and actually for you specifically you've
been in the world of this for a wide
Punisher war zone you work on arrow and
you've seen this growth from from the
inside what's it like to see yeah I mean
a Shazam movie in real life like to see
a two billion dollar Avengers end game
but having been there when Punisher war
zone was you know a ten million dollar
budget like this this growth in the in
the culture how's that been from the
inside well I think doing predator an
impressive seeing the alien and seeing
the 21 puppeteers with the mother alien
and you see the sort of the masa nations
of the practical puppet world and then
you realize the special effects that and
the technology that has improved over
the last 20 years where we can be doing
this now within the TV world it's very
heartening because what I saw was a
thread of commitment to this to this
literature to this genre that was never
ever never ever weakened brilliant Paul
Anderson for example when we did
Resident Evil he didn't CG he trained
all the zombies to walk they had a
choreographer come in so you really had
that sort of connection with and there
were certain people within my management
team and agents at that time like why on
earth would you want to get involved in
that stuff and I'm like well I see as
the the product the progress this is a
progression of literature and they're
right you're mad and then people would
say you know these young people playing
computer games why did editor and this
just a waste of time and I saying how
many people did say they should be
reading books and I said well how many
computer games have you play and these
guys were backed off and I said okay so
Hamm and how many people does it take to
write a book you know you have a right
to an editor in a little team this is a
collaborative effort everybody bring
something in so happy you be so negative
about this art form you shut them up
it's always baffled me because comics
are literally literature plus art yeah
and those are two things that separately
like that's so adult and the decision
put them together like mad kid stuff oh
yeah it's fascinating to see like we're
taking these shows so seriously this
yeah this is a Shakespearean effort this
is a a profound drama and yeah and I
think that that's a testament where we
are a society we were talking before
like we used to hide our spider-man
shirts look we used to like her 10 we
weren't as nerdy as we were and now it
is the biggest industry in the world
yeah as a fan now as part of it like
going from comic-con as a fan to
comic-con is as a piece of it what's
that like for you it's a joy like
because the thing is you know I used to
get bullied for it and there was the
kind of thing that I used to you know
it's not cool to like comic books and
now whenever I go to comic-con there are
hundreds of people who care what I think
about comic books and that's one of the
reasons why I love goings I actually
genuinely get to share my love of this
thing and that's why I think comic Comic
Con is such a special place in a special
time is that yeah it's super hairos and
pop-culture and all that sort of stuff
but for a lot of people this is
something that they feel that they have
to hide that they love this thing and
and for one weekend in San Diego
everyone gets together and they meet
like-minded people and they celebrate
this thing they love and it's something
that brings people together and makes
people feel less alone and that's
immensely important yeah it's been
nourishing people for a long time yes
these stories are nourishing wewe are
looking at the archetypes of our society
you know who were talking about Greek
myth nobody would look at it in any sort
of negative said yeah we've discussed we
discussed the Amaze the other side the
Odyssey we talked about that stuff on
set that's underpinning a lot of this
stuff and I feel in the world we're in
now I think it's so mad but the bottom
line is and I think comic conics totally
explores it but we stand alone together
mm-hmm
this is what we do we have to be down
these channels but we have that common
commonality and universality which is
extraordinary and then I see who was
looking at these games I see how diverse
the cast can be in this world of science
fiction and fantasy where I don't see
that in with respect to the history and
to the costume dramas of them that isn't
the world this is my world thank you so
much yeah universe you know and Jeff
John and all the people and all the
greats because this is this is a great
this is this is modern mythology and it
truly belongs to everyone
that is the strength of the genre of
comic books to me is that comic books
are all about reinvention mhm and and
finding a new interpretation and giving
especially young story tells a new story
tell us a chance with these fantastic
characters who've been around for a long
time I totally I mean it's young it's
it's a hero's journey it's all these
great archetypes but it's it's
translatable so yeah you walk down the
street you see a superman brand you
instantly are like oh that's one of my
people you feel this leadership this
culture and I think that Comic Con is
this rare hub how many other cultures
have a place where everyone gathers once
a year how the other and I think that
the particularly the show it modernizes
it while looking to the past and that's
such a hard balance to walk when you
found out the the extent of it being a
prequel and the concern about prequels
were you concerned as actors with the
fan reaction to doing something about
Superman without Superman I think and
look how I'm a fan too and I saw the
announcement I was thinking really you
know that'll never fly but then I saw
what they wanted to I saw they wanted to
do with it and it's it's that thing of
wit taking a real risk here yes this
show is not what people expect it to be
and that's what we wanted to deliver
absolutely and and I think youyou always
want to give people a shot and I think
that there there is there is some
healthy cynicism in in in in this
industry and and and in fandom but give
storytellers a shot because I think by
and large they want to take those risks
especially with these characters that
are so beloved to you because because
reinvention is is the key to these
stories and like the new 52 for example
in in DC Comics not all of it worked but
the course of ours was an absolutely
spectacular story yes I think a lot of
the stuff that Grant Morrison did in his
action comics run was brilliant mhm you
know in there and there are little bits
of and even if even if it doesn't work
out at least you get to see it it
doesn't work out and so for us we took a
big swing and done and thankfully for us
it's paid off and people are coming with
us on this journey which we are
immensely thankful they're very grateful
because at the end of day it's all about
the fans but you got to be willing to
take that risk and and for the fans
hopefully they're they're willing to let
us take a shot and I mean it has yeah
it's going it's going well
it shows in the the relationship with
the fans is there we were talking before
about how like the CW actors are some of
the kindest people did one every every
actor I've met that's a superhero stays
a superhero fans and I really appreciate
that because it's so important that kids
keep their heroes
what would your as people in the comic
space like gateway drug comic be I know
Tim Drake Robin sure I commend people
get into if they are in the world of
comics you know it depends it and then
we were saying for comics there's so
much constantly there's so much story
and it can be a little intimidating sure
the first thing I would I would
recommend is is find those character
that you like whether it's it's Batman
or Superman or Green Lantern whatever it
is and go down to your local comic book
shop because by and large I think that
that nerd fandom is really welcoming
it's a really welcoming community and
start conversations and don't be afraid
to ask questions and and maybe you're
really into a Justice League story or a
really big superhero fiction in which
case I'd recommend something like Batman
hush but maybe it's something you're
into some of this much more grounded in
which case it's a year one there is a
comic book of Ephram mm-hm I fully
believe that but for me the Gateway was
the animated series you know I was a
child of the 90s I grew up Bruce Timm
Andrea Romano animated series and and
you know Superman and Batman so I had a
cursory knowledge of who they were but
the comic that really made me a comic
fan was Jeff Jones Teen Titan run oh
because that was the thing that made me
realize how connected this universe is
and and how how much it depends on the
emotional relationships between these
characters and to see people like Tim
Drake being like I don't know if I want
to be Batman but also I don't know if
I'm as cool as Nightwing and and and to
see what they think about each other and
how they feel about each other and them
trying to find their place in this world
that was thing that opened up the whole
DC universe for me did you happen to
read the Tom Kings heroes in crisis oh
yeah the the are talking about like the
blips of the Robins talking about the
yeah and they're all sort of
insecurities be that was an amazing Tom
King right some of the best dialogue in
in comics for sure but that that story
as someone who has mental health you
know struggles every now and again that
was a really really important story in I
think is a fantastic story I think it's
one of most important comics on the
shelves right now and I think DCU a big
Doomsday Clock
the heroes in crisis
King doing phantasm bring oh my goodness
men like oh yeah god so cool world yeah
yeah well also he's writing new cause
now with Ava do a night like oh my
goodness that's so cool like experience
I can't wait to see that it went from my
I literally look forward to that to my
like number three most anticipated movie
that's been announced oh yeah oh yeah
higher swath of film yeah yeah what
first brought you into the world of
comics what was what was your first or
babbling bit like Cameron it was its
films it was always film it was always
the TV series the Batman series they're
the Dutch the way we've always in the
villains terrain it was on a Dutch but
really I was out there being trying to
be a superhero most the time yeah that's
my thing I just sort of been whenever he
got heavy I just imagine like I was that
guy so the Dark Knight Batman's always
been somebody special to me I think and
then seeing the success they if the
Black Panther movies now and that you
just see this this burgeoning the what
success of the Wonder Woman movie their
success and how my sons will play
characters with female characters with
that I thought yeah and that is progress
yeah and I think this genre allows for
progress to be not heavy-handed it's
this beautiful genre of acceptance and
that's that's the beautiful thing about
comics to me is like hey look we're all
equal let's just being and comics do
that for us
this show does that I love that you guys
have built a world where Zod is as
important as the grandfather of kal-el
and I love that we get to live in a
world where this the show exists and
then the class in the sci-fi I'm what
they're building so thank you so much
for being a part of this this very
important show and this this impossibly
important universe
thank you guys much for me it's very
kind of you thank I'm having absolutely
thanks guys